and the problem with work culture is
that it's trained too many young minds
like yours to forget about that
yes
[Music]
normally but you actually won all of
them over they were quite respectful uh
and I think I was probably you were
probably a bit surprised by the response
uh it's gone viral Global there's all
over America as well because it really
resonated with people I think rather
like me where you know I'm not right
wing uh I'm not left-wing I'm kind of
slightly Center I guess politically
about stuff a liberal more than not but
I find this Ultra work mentality so
illiberal that it borders on the very
fascism they profess to hate most so to
see you go into the lion's den a bit
with all these woke students and
actually what I thought was impressive
about it because it was a way he didn't
demonize it and maybe that is the way to
to progress and get this woke nonsense
dealt with properly is that you don't
demonize them you actually show them a
better way I think so and like you I I
identify as politically non-binary peers
and and so that that's angle I was
approaching from look the fact is both
you and I know that when we were 18 20
we were idiots as well and we were very
cocky and sure of ourselves and we
thought we knew the answers to
everything what we didn't have was the
internet to brainwash us and we didn't
have this very powerful ideology
actually wokeness is an ideology and
there's some very strong Concepts behind
it but that all aside and I thought I
found that I had a very interesting
encounter because you did you once have
seen this but we had to wait quite a
long time before the debate started and
I actually was talking to one of the
students in the bar and she she couldn't
believe that I even thought the woke
people existed like to her this was
unicorns but she came up to me after the
debate and asked for a selfie and that's
kind of what I thought really summed up
the whole experience you've got to
remember these are young people in their
mind they're open to persuasion we got
to make better arguments and I think
antagonizing people and we've all been
there you and I and everything else you
know my journey with my show
trigonometry it's been an evolution too
yes I haven't started out like this
necessarily but what I've come to now
and maybe it's being a father of a young
child now as well I'm starting to see
the you know these are kids and we we
have a responsibility to persuade them
to convince them with rational argument
and look when you're speaking to Bright
people like the ones at Oxford you've
got a chance one of the worst aspects of
mercury is the way that people now feel
too afraid to express opinions and it's
becoming a real thing where people you
know I had Dame Joan Collins on it
didn't want to say what she thought a
woman was and she's one of my favorite
people in the world Joan and obviously
knows what she believes a woman is but
didn't want to raise her head over a
parapet just to be shot down by the
trans Lobby or whatever whatever Lobby
it may be at any given moment there's
this mob mentality if you don't agree
with me you must be canceled immediately
shame vilified JK Rowling whoever it may
be have we got to this place what's
fueling it how do we deal with it well
first of all I know that you're shocked
by and I think a lot of people in the
west are shop but actually as someone
who grew up in the Soviet Union this is
very familiar I mean this is exactly
what we had and that's one of the
reasons I'm in this country is my
grandfather said the wrong thing and was
forced into Exile so this is actually if
you think about human history pretty
standard we just didn't expect it to be
happening in the 21st century and I
think technology is a big part of it
social media allows people to mob other
people the fuels also tribalism it fuels
this sort of righteous indignation the
victimhood don't forget there's also oh
there's real power and the power
actually manifests itself from the mob
going to corporate world and demanding
that they fire people and get rid of
people who don't agree with their view
exactly and I think a lot of people
particularly and you know this isn't an
attack but you know if you don't have a
lot of meaning in your own life this is
a way to get some meaning because you
tap this thing on your phone or on your
keyboard and suddenly a famous person is
getting canceled I think that's a big
part of it but as I say I'm just you
frankly point out I think the solution
here is to be reasonable to talk to
people to try and persuade them while
also of course we've got to stand up and
not allow these cancellations to happen
and that means that you know TV
producers and big corporations they have
to step up as well I mean I was forced
out of my last job for disbelieving Mega
mum which seems Preposterous now given
them nonsense that comes out of her
mouth
um but that showed me that when the mob
attacked the corporate world the
corporate world will often bow to them
all because actually they're just
terrified of the consequences a
terrified of losing advertising Revenue
sponsors and so on that's the way they
do it it's very well marshaled when
organized albeit there are quite a small
number of people they're just well
organized yeah and they're able to
create the illusion that there is a lot
of them because on social media you can
get a lot of Attraction with with not a
lot but I think you're right and I think
the fact is that we're building an
alternative ecosystem now shows like
mine on YouTube and uh there's going to
be companies that are making products
that don't care if you're woke or not
advertisers that are not interested did
in this stuff and I actually said this
on Twitter today I think the future
isn't work or anti-work the future is
post work we just got to move past this
well the trouble is the word has become
toxic originally what meant that you
were just more alert to racial and
social injustice yeah or we would all
sign up to that anyone with a brain and
a conscience would say yeah I can tell
them to but it's been hijacked yes yes
by the ultra wokies you basically are a
former fascist who are using this for
their own ends and I think that's why
both all of us have actually just got to
move past that and go this is appear in
human history which was pretty stupid
let's move on let's see how we can work
together and Spears we've got to change
the way that we have political
conversations in this country because
that's where this polarization is coming
from and we carry on down this path it's
very dangerous well that's so tribal as
well and toxic and Hyper partisan fueled
Again by social media people don't want
to admit anything wrong with their size
right and it's so refreshing when
occasionally you hear one of them do it
you know you think wow there's someone
prepared to criticize their own sight as
if it's somehow a football team and you
can't admit to giving away a booking or
something why yeah how do we get to that
place in the Democracy the whole point
of democracy is that actually we have a
debate and we reach consensus well right
and that's why I quite often do is my
audience grows and expands I go out of
my way to annoy some of them to just
kind of position myself correctly
because I don't want to be playing to
any Eco chamber I'm trying to just be
honest about what I think
trigonometry you're gonna go gangbusters
on the back of this viral clip I mean
you surprised by how it's taken off and
he's going to sound arrogant but I'm not
I felt pretty good on the night
particularly you know no notes I noticed
yeah well yeah I I can't I'm pretty
clear on what I think about it now you
know we spend five years on trigonometry
interviewing all sorts of Fascinating
People you know the Douglas Murray's the
Jordan Petersons lots of people on the
left trying to understand what's going
on because you know the story of us is
it's two comedians didn't really know
what was going on but what we felt was
in comedy there was a lot of
hypersensitivity and outright censorship
going on we can understand where it was
coming from so we thought let's talk to
people who are smarter than us who can
explain what's going on and now I'm
pretty clear on what I think well you've
been trying to get me on trigonometry
for a while
now publicly agree and we're going to do
it at our mutual friends restaurant in
Portugal in Kensington Saturday I'll be
there let's put the wall to right